[Musique]
la question c'est
malgré un suivi médical serré geneviève
marcotte continue d'avoir de sérieux
symptômes de l'aco vide treize mois
après avoir contracté la maladie vous
avez seulement 1 2 heures dans les
magasins de la compagnie
j'ai presque une semaine en ville jadis
très active geneviève a dû retourner
vivre chez ses parents à 36 ans pour
l'instant il est impensable qu'elle
reprenne son travail de directrice des
missions commerciales à l'université
laval avec ma batterie est à 10% si
j'arrive à 12% si je dépense 12 %
d'énergie je fais un maïs vaste effort
et celle en fait que tous mes symptômes
réapparaissent
de façon vraiment exagéré que j'ai
encore des douleurs musculaires la poupe
qui avec une sensation de brûlure des
gros mots tête un épuisement qui laisse
qualité des gens comme geneviève ils en
passent beaucoup dans le bureau de son
ergothérapeute l' approche habituelle de
réadaptation qui implique parfois de
repousser les limites du patient ne
fonctionne simplement pas avec la
commune on sait comme l' inverse qui se
produit dès que les gens pour ce que
trop la limite ils crachent qui retombe
ni empire larcins temps avec les gens il
veut vraiment de l'incompréhension ou
une détresse du stress l'ampleur du
problème est difficile à quantifier la
cnss t qui couvre les gens ayant
contracté la co vide sur les lieux du
travail verse actuellement des
indemnités depuis plus de six mois à
cinq cent une personnes au québec mais
toutes celles qui comme geneviève ont
attrapé la maladie ailleurs qu'au
travail et sont couvertes par des
assureurs privés sont invisibles dans
les statistiques est-ce que je crois
qu'il ya des milliers de personnes qui
ne sont pas retournés à leur pleine
capacité de travail avant l'infection
oui sauf que certains le chercheur simon
décarie spécialiste en réadaptation
crois qu'on a socialement sous-estimé
les effets de l'aco vide sur le marché
du travail il en appelle à la
compréhension des assureurs et c'est pas
terminé en faible parce que l'on a les
données scientifiques démontrent que on
peut avoir un code que d'une longue à
trois morceaux
[Musique]
par-dessus une triple vaccination pin
une infection à le micro j'ai appris que
la meilleure façon ces grandes me
coucher un jour à la fois geneviève
apprend à gérer son nouveau quotidien
mais devant le temps qui s'étire les
questions fusent et les réponses
manquent encore quand j'arrivais au bout
de toutes ces ressources là que je
réponds par quart de travail c'est
qu'est ce qui va se passer gasquet
chavancy scénique ici alexandre duval
radio canada québec
[Musique]